and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review Hobbit an unexpected
jelly oh my god this is the greatest
movie I've ever seen in my life ash yeah
timba spoilers here Cicely took a knee
Bilbo Baggins you know he's the guy
Leonard Nimoy sings about all the time
ask your parents about that way and he's
asked to go on a prequel with the most
stereotypical wizard you've ever seen in
your life to help a bunch of dwarves get
their City back and their names are
blurry poori garland pollen I catch I
got back a shot got sneezy dopey smoky
cookie oh and then there's also the fat
barbarian who drinks too much you know
there was only like one in the group so
they're all to roam middle-earth which
I'm assuming is in between beginning
earth and after earth to defeat this
evil dragon who apparently has taken
away their city and all their gold
because dragons have a real love of
dwarf cities and a bunch of gold
what the heck is a dragon gonna do with
gold anyway does he just mean bling is
he trying to be Puff the Magic Daddy
oh I'm sorry Pete dragon though the
wizard decides to bring Bilbo for
reasons that are never really explained
he's going to be in burglar even though
they never said he could burgle anything
but he has a good heart which apparently
led the other toward seem to have good
hearts too but the Trident won't know
his stench which of course you probably
won't know the stench of another dragon
you could practice talk to them or an
echo hey where did he goes ever go we
didn't like half of these movies be over
if they just use the Eagles more I don't
know the Eagles would never make it far
enough to complete the mission they may
get pretty far in all these movies sales
calls in the most dangerous areas in all
the land and they seem to turn out okay
maybe their music is too annoyingly 70s
so even though Bilbo doesn't want to go
on the quest he suddenly decides he does
I want to go in your quest why I don't
really know but nobody can pronounce
your names and so mine is more
marketable crap he has a point
but things get really scary when they
come across three Giants racks and the
schecter like we have to eat them fast
before the Sun comes up why is that
because then we turn into stone hey
that's cool Disney should make a cartoon
out of that I'm sure they'd be great
until the last season though the Sun
comes up in tourism in
stone which again is a door third rolls
in the daylight in the other movie but
they still have to be careful because
they come across an evil white sausage
orc and they write their giant
werewolves that actually look worse than
the watch from 20,000 ever mentioned
Tolkien to Twilight same sentence again
he's an Edward skin is made out of miss
wheel they come across a bunch of cameos
from the other movies and their main job
is to be like all the stuff you saw in
the other movies is going to happen
no okay but the Bilbo is like ain't
going home of course you are there's
only two more of these movies left and
we're gonna do it without you well you
did the last one without Christopher Lee
and go out in Gollum ooh that enter/exit
mr. bean who sounds like Donald Duck
how are I'm not your brother must be
something in the round kernel with the
two precious how did you lose it it fell
out of the pot over my loincloth you
were tying to give you a link low
packets are processes great I read about
siren will tell you where deep if you
show me the way out of here I'm Tom
Foreman are very good by the way I have
to be brusque realize the last time I'll
ever Tressa Hamels and that's one of
them happens to look like Elijah Wood
he's creepily dreaming those words in
The Wizard of fighting off all the
goblins
I fight off a bunch of cabinets once I
was never invited to a Halloween party
again and The Hobbit is like when we've
established that I'm not going to leave
you so we can call this the end of part
one knowing there's some herbs over
there that clearly we should wait until
part two to fight and fight them and run
away okay now it's the end of part one
pray so the Hobbit an unexpected journey
was a really really good movie despite
the fact that the other three books got
a film apart and this is the shortest
one and somehow it gets three but I
think Peter Jackson wanted to make sure
that nothing was left out like that wood
wizard that was never in the book that
conversation with sorrow man and delay
hero those never in the punch but he was
he ready at least they didn't put in Tom
Bombadil the only character everyone
wanted to see the Lord arranged mummies
had never got a chance tone I might try
to see that Fisher King wizard smoked a
stick bug see if it's not a bad idea I
know what I'm doing for Christmas
this is jittery bum scene sadness Brad
you got laughs espresso come on up a guy
my lab and Fred come on sweet my stick
no your stomach and when you're smoking
a stick bug that's a good appetizer